З понад 150 рейсів на день залишилося не більше двох десятків.
Міжнародний аеропорт "Бориспіль", як і багато інших аеропортів світу,
закритий для регулярних пасажирських міжнародних авіаперевезень.
З 17 березня здійснюються лише так звані евакуаційні рейси
для повернення додому громадян України.
Йдеться про тих, хто застряг у туристичних подорожах,
або заробітчан, які втратили роботу в Європі і хочуть повернутися додому.
Українські авіакомпанії продають квитки на евакуаційні рейси в обидва боки.
Проте квиток - не гарантія потрапити на борт літака.
Ви мене випустите в Німеччину? У мене є квиток…
Якщо є якась гуманітарна мета, тоді буде окремо рішення ухвалюватися.
Скандали біля стійок прикордонників не вщухають вже кілька днів.
Це громадяни України, які мають постійне місце проживання за кордоном
і хочуть повернутися додому.
Але прикордонники таких пасажирів не завжди пускають.
Постановою Кабміну виліт з України дозволено лише іноземцям,
дипломатам або представникам міжнародних гуманітарних місій.
Для громадян України кордон фактично закритий на період національного карантину -
з 17 березня до 3 квітня.
Олена з Рівного мешкає в Європі вже 5 років,
має дозвіл на проживання в Ліхтенштейні і одружена з громадянином Ліхтенштейну.
Проте на рейс до Цюріха її не пустили.
Я українка, я маю паспорт і не можу виїхати. Чому?
Якщо зі мною щось трапиться, цей вірус, я маю право
за свою страховку, яку я плачу по 400-500 євро в місяць, отримати медичне
обслуговування там.
Тим більше, що Швейцарія дала довідку, що вони мене чекають там, у цій країні.
А наші не випускають.
Людмила Любомирська теж, маючи квиток, не змогла потрапити на рейс до Берліна 18 березня.
У  Німеччині вона постійно мешкає вже 22 роки і має там родину.
Жінка вважає, що її безпідставно утримують в Україні.
Нам весь час показують цю постанову Кабміну. Ми її всю прочитали. Зверху донизу, ліворуч, праворуч і у зворотний бік.
У цій постанові жодного слова немаєпро те, що нас не можна випускати
або що нам заборонено виїжджати. Жодного слова!
Вирішити цю проблему кілька днів намагалися посольства різних країн.
Зокрема, в посольстві Німеччини в Україні Deutsche Welle повідомили, що такі скарги
справді надходять, але що проблему неможливо вирішити,
допоки уряд України не змінить свого рішення.
Тож, постраждалі пасажири об’єдналися і почали відстоювати свої права самі.
Вони намагалися привернути увагу до своєї проблеми,
оприлюднюючи відео спілкування з прикордонниками в соцмережах.
Ось одна, дві три, чотири людини, які не представляються.
Або не пускають енну кількість людей.
І навіть пішли до Кабміну, аби чиновники почули про їхню проблему.
Хтось відповідає, хтось ні.
Йшла така собі гра в футбол. Ми були в Кабміні, я сказала, що не вийду звідти,
сяду там, тому що мені в Україні ніде жити. Вирішіть це питання!
Громадяни України, які постійно мешкають за кордоном,
також звернулися до урядів країн Євросоюзу, де вони живуть.
Проблема почала поволі вирішуватися, коли з’явилося повідомлення,
що Європейський Союз вирішив допустити до в'їзду на територію ЄС
через державний кордон України тих українських громадян, які є членами сімей громадян ЄС
або мають дійсні постійні або тимчасові дозволи на проживання в якійсь країні ЄС.
Ми хотіли виїхати 18-го березня. Я з дитиною. Дитина - громадянка США.
Мені запропонували, що дитина 4-х років може виїхати, а я залишаюся тут.
Нас три дні не пропускали.
Слава Богу, сьогодні дали добро - з документами і посвідкою про дозвіл на постійне проживання,
ми відлітаємо.
МЗС України поки не відповіло на запит Deutsche Welle про те, яким категоріям громадян України
дозволено виїзд з України.
Евакуаційні рейси будуть здійснюватися ще приблизно тиждень.
Приміром, на спецрейс до Тбілісі, який організовує Грузія,
дуже хоче потрапити Бесаріон разом зі своїми родичами.
У мене в Україні дядько, а у нього тут дружина і дитина - громадяни України.
Вони хочуть вилетіти в Грузію. Але нам кажуть, що дядько може вилетіти, але тільки без родини.
Поки також незрозуміло, чи повернуть авіакомпанії кошти за втрачені квитки,
які, за словами пасажирів, продавалися за шаленими цінами.
Я звернулася до нашої митниці, щоб отримати якийсь офіційний документ,
чому мене не випускають з країни! Я розумію, що зараз коронавірус, але я хочу повернути гроші!
Жоден з опитаних DW пасажирів поки такого документу не отримав.
Дехто збирається звернутися зі скаргою про порушення їхніх прав,
а також про відповідальність авіакомпаній,
які, на їхню думку, не припинили вчасно продаж квитків пасажирам з українськими паспортами.
Через пандемію коронавірусу у подібній ситуації
опинилися нині тисячі інших громадян по цілому світу.
Через скасовані рейси або закриті кордони люди застрягли в чужих країнах.
Більшість пасажирів, з якими поспілкувалася DW,
за останні три дні таки змогли вилетіти до країн, де вони постійно мешкають.
Вони створили окрему групу в соцмережах, де дають поради пасажирам актуальних рейсів.
Нині проблеми з вильотом все ще мають деякі громадяни України
з дозволом на проживання у США.